one of the greatest matches and upsets
in the world of chess occurred in 1960
there was a guy his name was Michael
bought Vinick he was considered the
patriarch of Soviet chess he was an
authoritarian kind of person who
believed there was a good way and a
wrong way and there was nothing in
between there was no shades of grey
yellow purple green lime nothing it was
black and white
there was a correct way of playing chess
and there was a stupid we're here
playing chess and Michael bought Vinick
was the world champion from 1946 till
1960 and he ruled Soviet chess with an
iron hand and as opponent was this wild
guy is Michael tall the youngest player
ever in the history of the game to
challenge for the World Championship and
tall wasn't matter he was a
swashbuckling guy who just threw his
pieces he attacked he sacrificed
everybody was supposed to play correct
chess defend your pawns get a small
advantage drag your opponent into an end
game and win tall was at the absolute
opposite you've never seen two opposing
players like Michael tall and Michael
authentic one there are many great books
about chess I have my 10 all-time list I
have my hundred all-time list but in
everybody's list is the book by benek
tal 1960 World Championship match by
Michael tall he wrote with such a
beautiful eloquence
he really made you the reader feel like
you were sitting right beside him and it
was almost like he would be explaining
what he was trying to do and what he
thought and well maybe that wasn't so
good and you almost expected him to turn
to you and say what do you think reading
his book it's that good and the first
time I read the book I felt that my
understanding of chess it increased a
lot
few years later I was bored I don't know
exactly how but maybe the book fell off
the shelf and hey I remember this is
like an old friend let me read it again
by this time I was actually a chess
master a very strong chess player and I
read it again and the health I was
reading it for the first time I was like
amazed it's like wow my understanding
had grown so much but the I thought I
had read it and understood it all no now
I was ready to understand more and of
course the story continues now I'm an
international Grandmaster and one of the
world's best players top ten in the
world preparing for the World
Championship candidates tournament in
Montpellier France the book fell off the
shelf again I read it for the third time
and again I felt like I was reading it
for the first time this is an
extraordinary book the very very gifted
writer and really regardless of your
playing strength I can absolutely assure
you you will be better off having played
having read the book now crazy man is
playing the black pieces good
authoritarian discipline
is playing the white pieces big big big
shock has happened in Game one
Michael tall has caught bawd Vinick in
an opening I'm not going to say trap
he has won the game from the opening and
has won Game one four draws so after
five games the pirate is leaving now Bob
Vinick needs to write the ship and win
with the white pieces okay Majdanek was
an English as well as Queen pond player
and he remained true to his English and
Queen pond openings as white throughout
his career
Michael tall just like we saw in our
game with Peter vyasa's love the Kings
Indian defense he loved it very much
so of course Michael Bennett could be
expected
Michael tall could be expected to play
the Kings Indian defense but Vinick
would be well-prepared G 2 G 3 so the
idea behind this move is both sides
fianchetto and then when white castles
and he's got a fortress he figures he
has an extra two defender on g2 to
withstand this Kings Indian defense
kinds of attacks so G 2 G 3 I showed you
the London system from earlier Bishop g7
Bishop g2 castles d4 all very very
standard opening chest Theory d7 d6
Knight c3 Knight B d7 castles ePHI you
recall in the earlier lecture I was
talking how black often in the Kings
Indian likes to play the move e5 and I
had brought my Bishop to f4 with a
deliberate purpose of undermining my
opponent from playing that move okay II
five e4 c6 everything is all very very
standard white has built up a very
imposing Center the e4 d4 see four pawns
they control all of these squares blacks
position however is quite flexible he is
ready in some case
to capture this pawn and bring his
knight either to the e5 or the c5 square
he's ready for a center of ants and he
can shut down the center keep it locked
up so it's a very flexible system but
today's grand masters like White's
position because we like space you like
controlling more of the board but these
were the this isn't so to speak a
tactical risk but essentially what
Michael Hall is doing is he's taking on
a strategic risk that if things don't
work out for him he may just have a
terrible position with no space for his
pieces h2 h3 this is a very common move
basically what white wants to do is he
wants to develop his Bishop to e3 but he
doesn't want to be harassed by the move
Knight g5 so white first plays the move
h3 protecting the g4 square it's a multi
it's a double dual purpose move to stop
both Knight g4 and maybe down the road
to stop Bishop g4 when the knight would
be in a pin and it basically says your
turn how are you going to handle these
great Center pawns
well tal says I'll show you Queen b6
another violation of the rules we chess
coaches we love our principles we are
men and women of principles and if you
don't like them we have other principles
too okay so we got lots of principles so
you tell me what you like I'll keep that
one of the principles that we like to
tell our students don't bring out your
Queen early if you bring out your Queen
early there's a potential that I'll be
able to attack the Queen with tempo I'll
develop with tempo against the Queen but
this violation of the rules is again
typical of Michael tall he's forcing the
play so we can see that this queen
eyeballs the pawn on b2 so you can't
just develop your Bishop to e3 because
I'll take the pawn on b2 if you decide
well I'll play rook B what oops sorry
I'll play rook b1 then you're in for a
little bit of a surprise see there's
Bishop on g7 it's sitting over here in
an ambush it's just waiting for an
opportunity to make a tactical play down
this diagonal black would capture this
pawn on d4 white would recapture the
punt and then suddenly ferocity
that's the Dutch for surprise surprise
surprise Knight takes e4 this pawn is
protected by the knight protected by the
bishop but now this Knight is suddenly
attacked by this bishop and after Knight
takes e4 Bishop takes d4 black is very
happy with the outcome of this rather
forcing light so in fact the move Queen
b6 has a threat of pawn takes d4 but
remember that rule our rule is don't
bring out the Queen early bring out the
Queen early you could be potentially
attacked but then it decided to play the
move d5 this was what we would call or
described as the safe solid move since
there was this a threat to take this
pawn on d4 by playing d5 this Bishop is
shut down it's in its inactive but it's
not the most challenging move in the
position the most challenging move in
the position would have been c5
attacking blacks Queens play might have
continued takes takes so now there's a
trade of one pawn each
but notice that this Knight doesn't have
a good square the knight moves to h5 g4
would trap the night the night would be
forced to go back to the hospital 98 but
this move 98 exposes this pawn on e5 to
attack the variation would continue
Knight a for attacking the Queen this is
a very important move with the knight on
a 4 notice the knight Forks both the
Queen and the pawn by the time this guy
gets captured this guy will get captured
as well it's a very forcing line Queen
to b5 defending the pawn bishop to f4
defending this pawn Knight to c7
bringing the knight out of the hospital
Queen to c2 c4 rook t1 all of these
moves are very what the players agreed
afterwards would have happened this was
like what they call analysis Soviet
analysis and the resulting position is a
little bit better for white that is to
say it's four versus well pardon me at
six versus six pieces are still being
figured out you can't play the move b5
at forking the Queen in the night
because of Queen c5 but the outcome of
this lengthy analysis is to show that in
later games people stopped playing
Michael halls move Queen b6 because of
the move c5 as the analysis showed that
white would get the superior position
instead by benek play d5 very very
typical by Vinick and basically what he
wants to do is throttle his young
opponent just keep control control the
tactics don't don't let tall create yeah
handcuff him
takes on c5 takes on c5 so White has
this very nice center wedge and blacks
pieces are pressed but it's very
impressive how blacks Michael tall
maneuvers around the structure let's see
what he did first of all he developed
his Knight very nice outpost opens up
the bishop so that he can develop the
bishop and put some pressure on the pawn
on e4 91 in the hospital but defending
the pawn on e4
Michael bought Vinick considers this
night to be very powerful so much so
that he's willingly trades that Knight
strategic chess is just that it's
strategic in the stretch strategy what
does that entail strategic chess is
simply this what are the good pieces
that you got what are the bad pieces
I've got but Vinick says this is a good
piece let me get rid of it hence he
plays 93 in order to trade off the good
piece as we know from strategy rooks
love open files bring your rook to the
open pile and the only open file in the
position is the C file
so Michael tall brings his rook to the C
file where it's active rook b1 again
white would simply love to play the move
Bishop e3 attacking blacks Queen
developing the bishop with a gain of
tempo the Queen takes b2 is a real
painful move because now not only did
the Queen capture upon but the pawn that
was supporting the knight means that the
knight is now
unprotected so before playing the move
Bishop e3
Michael Tao plays rook b1 defending his
b2 pond and preparing to gain a to play
with a gain of tempo not h5 what's that
what's that got to do with anything
the knight goes to the edge of the board
who is this bandit you know on the black
side over here Knight h5 hmm he clearly
doesn't understand a cold logic and
Bishop e3 was played gaining time
attacking the Queen Queen goes to b4
still not backing away offering white
even more opportunity to attack the
Queen however in case of a three the
Queen would settle in on the b3 square
and you can't push him any further Queen
came back to e2 the idea behind this
move Queen e2 just to keep a very
watchful eye on this night in case black
plays f5 and after trade you black will
not be able to capture with recapture
with the pawn because the knight is
hanging the Queen also drops back to
protect this pawn on b2 in order to be
able to release the rook from its
defense of the b2 pawn rook c4 active
play this is really tall in his element
and when you study the games of Michael
tall what becomes incredibly obvious is
how desirous he was in making his pieces
as active as possible he proposed his
rook up on c4 the most active Square
rook the C one doubles rooks and now
Michael tall plays a very tidy move you
remember when your mom and dad would
tuktuk you into bed well this is exactly
what white does with his King
it tucks it away he puts it in the safe
pocket it's like save zone the first
rank is cleared so that there's no back
rank checks and it basically says hey
I've got a really good position what do
you have your bishops are quiet your
knight is offsides and one day I'm going
to start kicking your pieces back maybe
with a 3 B 3 or maybe Bishop f-15 very
very bold play pawn takes f5 Bishop
takes f5 rook a 1 now this was the
position where that bought Vinick was
aiming for he really thought that black
was in deep doo-doo they didn't call it
doodoo in those days essentially white
is ready to play g4 for King Bishop and
Knight if the bishop goes away
voluntarily this night will end up on
this dominant square efore and blacks
Bishop isn't doing anything the knight
isn't doing anything in bud Vinick
considered it himself
close to strategically winning just one
two three more little nuances and over
tal agree Kyle had to do something about
it he sacrificed his knight though of
course metaphor well this of course
needless to say came as a great shock to
I mean literally in those days of the
Soviet Union chess was extremely popular
in the sense of a Bolshoi Ballet ow
halls with a thousand seats could be
filled I have gone to the Soviet Union
in the 70s and I personally witnessed
Hall being absolutely absolutely filled
beyond capacity and I remember my friend
Alexander avoid kovitch he was a young
boy here's my age at the time and he was
the second the trainer can you imagine
for Michael tall and we have visited the
playing hall and I could barely barely
squeeze my way into the entrance once I
got into the entrance I was literally
smashed against the wall and I had to go
all the way around the theatre and I was
like like you know 20 persons deep and
much to my amazement boy kovitch was
pressed up against the wall as well and
he looked at me and he was really
excited there to do with the big game
Michael tall versus bent Larsen he was
really excited and he said to me it's
more crowded than a bus in Kiev I never
went to Kiev but I understood that's a
pretty crowded bus right well when Paul
played the move Knight f4 literally the
hall goes nuts everybody starts talking
once whole by everybody pointing
everybody shouting and they had those
big neon sign things and you could just
see the arbiter he's pushing the button
silent shut up quiet
hey let the players think whoa so bad
Vinick has really you know knocked back
on his heels because that move came out
of nowhere
now obviously the knight is incredibly
powerful here it attacks the bishop it
attacks the Queen and if you don't take
it well your king is going to be
compromised that bishop will be captured
so of course white captured and black
captured so let's understand what just
happened Black Knight goes off the board
Wow white lost upon and the deal but
look at what's left on the board first
of all this bishop is under attack you
can't capture the pawn because then the
rook will capture the
bishop and that will be a great trade
for black secondly notice that this
bishop diagonal has been open we've
already been talking about the ideas of
Queen takes b2 if that ever happens with
that Bishop opening that will be great
for black next notice that this a moment
ago how snug and quiet and say and
peaceful whites King would suddenly
that's not the case this Bishop on g7 is
ready to jump to e5 putting uh instant
threats against White's King in other
words tall has created chaos the guy you
were supposed to control the guy and you
know you stop the tactics not even
Michael bud Vinick could do it but then
it played the move Bishop d2 and like a
lot of tall sacrifices they were
intuitive yeah they were also
psychological in the sense that he you'd
like to force his opponent into problems
that they hadn't been considering so in
this situation there was actually two
moves for Babinec he played the safety
move Bishop d2 when he could have and
should have played the move Bishop takes
a seven just a second let me make sure
I'm on the right variation I've actually
done the the annotations oh sorry no
cancel I blew it
I blew it so the bishop is going to move
but it's very important first of all
that this move a to a3 gets tossed it
attacking blacks Queen will understand
why in a moment after a three the Queen
would come to b3 and now we take this
pawn bishop takes
seven well at first sight you think to
yourself we'll wait a minute
after Bishop e5 f3 b6 look at the
position all of blacks pieces are very
actively posted and this Bishop might
just end up getting trapped once a rook
attacks the bishop if the Queen had been
on this square there would be Queen a5
so it was very important to play a three
but now comes a very nice move a form
it basically says two black excuse me
I'm ready to play a5 and I'll get my
Bishop back into the game it was
considered that after a four tall
sacrifice would have been refuted and it
took to play it took the journalists and
the grandmasters many hours to discover
this reputation and Michael Tao said
with a smile hours of analysis and
minutes of your clock during the
tournament or two different things when
your clock is ticking and you've got to
make a decision it's not as easy when
you're home in your study trying to
figure out the best move
Bob Minich played Bishop to d2 and now
Queen takes b2 was played so that's a
second pawn and this Knight this Queen
all being attacked by Vinick however had
a really cool move BAM
rook v1 turning the tables turning the
tables because now the Queen's under
attack and in White's mind white can see
a variation where the Queen goes away
rook takes b7 followed by Queen e7 and
suddenly it's black
being checkmated okay so rook b1 and tal
the play what did Michael tal do f3 holy
cow
what's that f3 attacking the Queen
attacking the bishop what's the purpose
of f3 well at this point by then ik and
time trouble heard what he had been
expecting was Bishop takes b1 rook takes
be one Queen c2 Bishop b4 nice blacks
queen is trapped the only move is rook
e8 Queen takes rook Queen takes 92 this
was bad vinick's calculation he's a
piece up and winning now when you throw
in this move f2 f3 however different
things start happening first of all the
e2 square would be under control as well
as a Bishop e5 check so what happened
after f3 excuse me was bought Vinik
errored with cap he wants to he's a
piece up he wants to trade trade off
Queens but he did it wrong he had to
play instead Bishop takes f3 Bishop
takes rook takes Queen c2 now if we look
at this position we think to ourselves
okay we've got two pieces for the rook
but crazy things are happening and then
we start noticing or wait a minute
Black's King is a little vulnerable
there are ideas of Queen b6 check ideas
of rook takes b7 and suddenly you start
to spot something
Bishop b4 Queens trapped only move now
if we take with the Queen this guy we
have to think or rook takes but look
what we have instead Knight takes e4 ooh
we're sacrificing a rook nut queen tags
and suddenly blacks and exchange up oops
Knight takes D 6 and now we're
threatening the smother checkmate with
Queen b6 check as well as Knight takes
the final position is advantage to black
moat the moment we see this last move
wait a minute more when you see this
last move we go
oh I understand earlier black should
have played Bishop to e5 check that way
you wouldn't be able to play Knight
takes D 6 the pawn would be protected
but let's have a look-see let's see if
black could have done that oops sorry
Bishop takes f3 Bishop takes rook takes
Queen c2 Bishop g4 let's imagine Bishop
e5 check oh sorry sorry rook takes
Knight takes Bishop e5 check new
variation came to g2 Queen takes now
maybe blacks winning right
no and Knight takes anyway
Knight takes anyway and in case of
Bishop takes d6 Queen b6 check attacking
rook attacking King white is for choice
these are very very complicated lines
and it's easy to understand how a player
makes mistakes when his clock is ticking
under under pressure and a lot of
calculation complications so if these
world champions can make tactical
mistakes trust me when I say mere
mortals can do it as well okay as it
turned out bob bennett played this
errored with rook takes b2 and suddenly
pawn takes eetu and look at this punt
how did that guy get there you ask
yourself but that Bishop on g7 is
attacking the knight and black is now
winning the game but then it defended
his knight and now came rook to d4
Bishop II won Bishop e5 check King g1
the bishops make a very beautiful
viewpoint don't they now what would you
do if you were black what move would you
make
now way brilliant that that would but we
we say Michael tall is a genius and he
was and is but he didn't make the best
move rook takes Knight was was winning
he chose a different method that was
also winning that was not as precise
rook takes in order to win control over
the d1 square though the game would have
continued rook takes rook to d1 now
threatening to capture the room notice
that you can't play rook see a check as
that square is protected by the Bishop
rook c7 Bishop f4 attacking the rook and
the best that white could do is play the
move rookie seven losing his rook and in
this position basically black has an
extra pawn on the Queen side as well as
very very good control with Israel his
pieces are better placed than whites and
he's material ahead this was the the
best way of finishing the game tall saw
a different idea he played Bishop f4
similar to the met the previous
variation tall is expecting that he will
take the knight and follow it up with
rook d1 the bob Vinick had Knight takes
rook takes Knight takes rook takes
Bishop here so basically Botvinnik has
struggled his way into a very difficult
if not lost position actually I think
it's lost but at all could have been
more precise Bishop efore and these
moves f4 very important this is a this
absolute pin is a real nasty one and
what white does with this move f4 is he
wants to be able to play King to f2 Kyle
has a very nice rejoinder Bishop h4
Bishop f6 pardon me so
the idea is that he's ready to meet King
f2 with Bishop h4 check protecting his
rook rook takes b7 Bishop takes d5 rook
c7 and the players I think we're still
uh yes so they had a few more moves to
go before they got into adjournment
now in those days it wasn't that long
ago what often happened is they had what
were called five-hour playing sessions
so the idea is that you and I sat down
together we played a game of chess
together after five hours we're kind of
tired maybe we need to go either drink
or go to the bathroom or what have you
the game was stopped it was what was
called adjourned and then we would
resume in the evening or the next day
and I had lots and lots of adjournments
and World Championship matches were
famous for their Germans and very often
times adjourned positions were put in
newspapers and the chess amateurs from
all over the world would analyze that
frozen position and then they would send
telegrams to the players to say I found
the move for you and you would literally
sift through thousands of telegrams
during the match between Bobby Fischer
and Boris Spassky for example hundreds
if not thousands of telegrams were sent
to Bobby Fischer and he had to turn off
all telephones because people would call
and say you know I think you could beat
Boris Spassky and this is my suggestion
that how you could do it thank you very
much now go away really really all right
we are getting close to it the players
are still in time trouble and they're
about to get into it and German position
so all of these moves were played and
finally after all of that action what
does it come down to a simple rook and
pawn endgame Black has three pawns White
has two pounds this past pawn the past
see pawn black wants to support the plas
C pawn with his King and to force white
to give up his rook for it
after King d5 rook down c3 rook goes
behind King comes to d4 and the game was
adjourned so at this point home analysis
blah blah blah
they said that the position is wet one
for black and so Michael bud Minik
resigned the game and after six games he
was behind by two points in the match
and although the match was a twenty four
game match this two point lead proved to
be insurmountable and Michael Hall
became the youngest Grand Master in
history records as we say our men are
made to be broken and it was only Garry
Kasparov in 1985 when he defeated
Anatoly Karpov in the second match to
became the youngest world champion
narrowly edging out bad vinick's record
means amazing well thank you